Joe how would one develop an idea first
for the web series I mean to someone
look at what to make versus a type of
web series that avoid that hasn't been
filled already are you looking to fill
certain demographic in registry what's
popular right now or they go off what
inspires them I would go more with a
ladder with inspiring because I I'm not
a fan of making calling cards I'm not a
fan of writing from demographics I don't
I don't think that you can think up a
story and go well that's what a 24 year
old woman who wants to buy a Volvo would
watch because that's shitty storytelling
I think write what you know is going to
be fun to write and work your ass off on
and that is going to take everything out
of you because it's got to be it's got
to be work it's got to be fun it's got
to be worth it and I think that if you
were like I have a vampire show there
are a lot of vampire shows part of the
inspiration was to find another way into
that genre and it was part of the
thinking but I wrote a show that has
profanity in it I wrote a show that is
you know my vampire rules are know when
sparkles there's no romance it's a
sighting a different approach to it but
what I I love bad guys I love crime that
whole I was a bartender in Boston had
mafia regulars so I kind of felt like I
knew a little bit about that world and I
just seemed like the perfect mix of
things so I think if you're if you're
thinking about making the show imagine
that there is no television industry
there is no film industry the
entertainment industry doesn't exist now
what story do you want to tell because
the only thing the entertainment
industry is going to bring you is people
telling you know people telling you what
to do people telling you what not to do
lots and lots and lots and lots of
and part of those the rules are who's
your demographic who's going to watch
this if you were going around town
trying to get permission trying to get
somebody to say yes think of do that if
you see this as the first time in the
history of storytelling that you can
create something at a quality that has
never been achievable for this price
that you can show to an audience around
the world on the internet as not the
greatest thing in the world because so
much of this has been about yes as a no
so much of this has been about please
let me tell the story sure we're going
to fire you now and bring in our writer
and our director and completely change
everything you do or what we'd like this
this and this because it'll be good for
the sponsor or we all want this because
we can't get sponsorship my thinking is
find some way to do it with as little
as you possibly can because the
more you have to deal with the
more it slows you down or you're waiting
for somebody else to give you permission
it's to me it's like this is the perfect
opportunity to be able to tell stories
so I think if you can come up with a
story that you can get the cash find the
cash find somewhere around it
incorporate the budget into the idea of
the story make it make it a
consideration like when I write vampire
mob I'm thinking about beware where is
this location while I'm writing and if I
know that location then I know where
we're going to shoot it while I'm
writing it so that's save so much time
in and pre-production lowers my budget
we do a lot of guerrilla shoots we do a
lot of no permit shoots we have lookouts
sometimes what we're shooting it's not
every base cup of tea but I
don't have a problem with it and we've
been very very lucky enough shot like
125 pages just on the show without
permits and never had a problem but so
so I think it's a combination of
thinking what store you wanna what score
do you really want to tell what can you
afford to tell or figure out a cheap way
to tell and starting from there because
once you once you start thinking like
that then you need less people than you
need less you know you don't need a
giant company go here's money you know
you don't need to do a Kickstarter
$50,000 campaigning and shrank I think
it trains your head as a book because I
write it i directed i produce it I
headed it I fundraise for it I promote
it I cast it so if I'm doing all those
things and I know that I'm doing it
without having to go is this person okay
for you I'm going to cast this person is
that person okay to a company to a
producer to someone who's overseeing it
focus on the freedom focus on what you
the story you want to tell and the best
way that you can tell it would be my
advice and not everybody agrees with
that it's probably antithetical to
marketing to finding a sponsor but if
your story's really good and
your audience knows like the vampire mob
audience knows how we make this show
they've seen oh shoot the show I talk on
Twitter about making the show I blog
about it so they know that we are just
just a few people with cameras shooting
in somebody's kitchen or stealing shots
out in the street or whatever we're
doing and that becomes the personality
of the show it becomes for lack of a
better term the brand of the show that
we like these indie people that were
just like it let's just go do this
and go do it
you